foreign
hey this is an amazing time to be a
developer isn't it yep even for pretend
developers like me hi I'm Richard and it
is easy to overlook the fact that all of
you can build and deploy software
anywhere in the world nowadays how cool
is that yet at the same time we're also
expected to know this inhumane amount of
things about coding languages app
Frameworks build systems security
practices modern infrastructure
infrastructure automation yep even Cloud
platforms to it is a lot
we've got even more people coming into
this amazing Tech World thanks in part
to AI but while AI is quickly changing
the role of technology in our day-to-day
work the cloud experience itself hasn't
changed a whole lot over this past
decade it's mostly been a do-it-yourself
model that you stitch together through a
maze of options buried in uis and clis
and apis it's all on you honestly we've
seen the cloud go from overwhelmingly
exciting to just well overwhelming let's
fix that here at Google we are aiming to
make it easier for cloud users of all
skill levels to cut through the toil and
build some breakthrough experiences
we're tackling this through our AI
Investments across four areas I'll
summarize them first and then we'll go
into depth on each one first we're
introducing a brand new generative AI
powered interface for Google Cloud this
new interface fundamentally transforms
the cloud development experience by
using AI Foundation models to surface
contextual code completion and
prescriptive chat based assistance
wherever you are in the console it's
time that someone reinvented the cloud
with AI at the center of your experience
and that's what we've done
second in addition to that new interface
we recently introduced new generative AI
products and solutions to help you
easily build gen apps and create new
experiences like Bots and chat
interfaces custom search engines digital
assistants and more
third we're offering our AI optimized
infrastructure that's designed for your
highly demanding AI workloads and then
finally we've also embedded Ai and
products like Google workspace to make
it easier for you to create connect and
collaborate let's dig into each one and
why we're excited about it
Cloud users spend way too much time
context switching when writing code
debugging or onboarding this new
generative AI powered interface is a
first in the public cloud and it's for
cloud years of any skill level what
makes this new AI powered interface
differentiated for our customers is they
can provide assistance wherever you need
it within the IDE Cloud console or even
in chat this means that all of you can
create faster whether you're a developer
operator data engineer security
professional or even those who don't
know how to code
the underlying model is also pre-trained
with Google Cloud expert content meaning
you get smart contextual recommendations
when building all those Google Cloud
apps
this interface starts with code
assistance which comes built in as part
of this new interface and provides
developers with AI driven code
completion and generation we're baking
this into Ides and also directly within
that code writing experience anywhere in
the cloud console
there's also a brand new chat interface
that you can engage with to learn how to
use cloud services get architectural
best practices and more without having
to go from all this different
documentation in one another let's cut
down on all that context switching let
me show you all this in a pretty quick
demo
let's say I want to build an app and
deploy this Hello World app wherever I
want to go here you can see code
assistance generates code for a Hello
World app and Cloud workstations
remember that's our fully managed secure
Dev environment in the cloud in this
example code assistance is working in
Cloud workstations but the same
experience can be unlocked in other Ides
like Cloud shell editor or Cloud code or
extension to visual studio code and any
other IDE
we're also supporting this across
multiple languages like Java python go
and JavaScript
as my Hello World app grows so with my
requirements so for starters I might
want to leverage other Google Cloud
products like database or storage code
assistance can help you it automatically
generates code to connect to Google
Cloud products like cloud storage
as I mentioned earlier this assistance
isn't limited to Ides and is available
in other parts of the Google Cloud
interface where you code this includes
Cloud functions or even here in bigquery
where now you can see contextual SQL
completion
it's not just limited to code completion
and generation remember you also have
chat with this conversational assistant
to get guidance on specific Cloud tasks
for example you could get a reminder on
how to use the gcloud commands to enable
an API or learn more about a good best
practice here I'm asking for help
deploying my app to Google Cloud run
or if you're someone working in
operations it gets stuck like I always
do when trying to figure out how to
update IAM policies just ask the
conversational assistant this embedded
assistance throughout Google Cloud
totally changes how I've been writing
apps and minimizes the time I spend
bouncing back and forth between tasks
ai-backed chat assistance is great but
we're taking it one step further to make
it possible to describe and create
applications in app sheet with no code
to show you this let's look at the new
generative AI power chat assistant
within app sheet let's say Ann is a
manager and she often receives travel
requests via email and chat a travel
approval app would allow her to manage
these requests luckily her team uses app
sheet so this new chat assistant within
app sheet can help her build and refine
this travel approval app so Anne heads
over to the app sheet chat app section
where she's prompted to describe the
type of experience she's looking to
create
she starts by using natural language to
enter a short description of her
requirements for the travel request app
Sheet's gen AI chat assistance uses this
input to automatically begin building
her application for her
from there the assistant walks her
through the process step by step asking
her a series of questions
once the questions are answered after
she actually creates the app
and is then prompted with options to
edit or preview the app
she selects preview and sees what's been
created
now Anne has this fully functional app
complete with a database notifications
views even sample data she takes a quick
look to see what else the app may need
and realizes it would be useful to see
how her team is spending their travel
budget and asks appsheet to add it
app sheet shows and the updates it will
make and then she confirms it yes
and now has a new screen called
travelspend in the app where she can see
an aggregated spend by team member she's
pretty happy with this version and then
she shares it with the team
now whenever someone on the team
requests travel approval and gets a
notification message in chat she can
approve or reject that request right
from the chat interface
this is how AI powered assistance can
quickly and easily Empower Cloud users
of all technical skill levels to
describe create and share apps without
ever writing a single line of code
that's wild
while leveraging the new AI powered
interface is pretty cool many developers
may be looking to build their own
generative AI apps until now though it's
been kind of difficult for orgs to
access all these generative AI models
let alone customize them for their
specific use cases this is why with
generative AI supported in vertex AI
we're providing a wide variety of
foundation models from Google via an API
with a full Suite of tuning options for
customizing Foundation models
you can choose how to customize these
Foundation models based on your use case
with a wide range of tuning options from
low code tools to Advanced fine-tuning
for low code tooling vertex AI provides
a simple interface that makes it easy to
use natural language prompts and user
data to customize that model
for foundation models in vertex AI we
introduced the Palm API back in March
this unlocks use cases like creative
content generation chat summarization
natural language QA and more with our
new text embeddings API developers can
build more sophisticated apps based on
semantic understanding of text including
long form text
examples include semantic search
recommendation engines text
classifications Qi and even more
we provide a full Suite of tooling for
building these jet apps including
state-of-the-art Vector database called
vertex AI matching engine
and now you can build with more than
just text on vertex AI today we're
pretty excited to announce the
availability of three New Foundation
models accessible via API on vertex AI
image generation for creating high
quality images from text inputs code
completion and generation leveraging
your code base
and a universal speech model
which brings state-of-the-art accuracy
for speech to text and over 300
languages
we're also combining the power
Foundation models with Enterprise search
and conversational AI to enable
developers to help Define how they want
generative AI to surface in their apps
Enterprise search complements the
foundation models to help provide
factual update information
conversational AI helps developers make
interactions within their apps a little
more human-like a little more helpful
this is all orchestrated through our new
tool called generative AI app builder
even developers with limited machine
learning skills can quickly and easily
tap into the power of Google's
Foundation models search experience and
even the conversational AI Technologies
to create these Enterprise grade gen
apps
with Gen app builder developers can
quickly ship new experiences with
templates for Bots chat interfaces
search engines digital assistants even
more let's see it in action shall we
symbol bikes wants to enable a more
natural human-like conversations with
their customers they're multimodal they
want to go beyond just information to
complete transactions
it also wants to transform the search
experience for its employees by letting
them perform natural language search
queries across the Enterprise data and
get answers that combine a variety of
data sources and then synthesizes the
summaries it makes researching a breeze
I start by logging onto Gena app builder
and adding relevant data sources such as
my company's URL and some internal
documents
gen app builder can power both a search
and chat experience so let's create both
gen app builder quickly creates these
out of the box experiences which we can
then easily preview to ensure they're
working
with granular controls I can fine tune
the search experience by boosting search
parameters enabling and disabling
features or even modifying the UI
likewise for chat I can choose what type
of responses to allow or data to access
using pre-built workflows for common
tasks such as checking order status or
even just create a whole new custom
workflow I can even enable customer
transactions
once I'm done with customization I can
easily deploy these experiences to a
bunch of places like websites or
internal data sets for chat Bots I can
even deploy within popular messaging
apps or unique chat technology from our
telephony partners that's it within
minutes I can build gen AI powered
search and chat applications
all of these new gen AI capabilities
from Google Cloud empowered developers
to responsibly build with Enterprise
level safety security and privacy and
ensures organizations have complete
control over how if and for what their
data is used
building for the future requires
enormous amounts of computation both to
train all these underlying machine
learning models and to serve those
models once they're trained Google cloud
and its ecosystem provide a wide range
of compute options for use cases such as
large language models generative Ai and
diffusion models and today we're taking
these options a step further by
announcing A3 virtual machines based on
nvidia's h100 GPU together with the A3
VMS and the recently announced G2 VMS
based on L4 gpus Google Cloud offers a
complete range of GPU options for
training and inference of ml models all
these Investments bring a new level of
Simplicity to Google Cloud are you ready
for a new Cloud experience we're just
getting started if you're interested in
joining The Trusted tester program for
our new AI assisted Technologies you can
sign up here buckle up this is going to
be fun
now let me hand this over to Yuli to
talk about the latest updates to
workspace and how they're providing new
opportunities for Developers
[Music]
hi I'm Julie Kwan Kim vice president of
product for workspace platform I'm
excited to show you where the Google
workspace platform is going and
opportunities for AI to supercharge help
people work at workspace our mission is
to meaningfully connect people so they
can create build and grow together
workspace is the world's most popular
productivity tool our community of
developers build on the workspace
platform to serve over 3 billion users
and 9 million paying customers our
customers range from individuals running
a small business to some of the world's
largest companies
additionally over 5 billion apps and
add-ons have been installed from our
Marketplace extending the capabilities
of our platform to help people do even
more
developers can find success on the
workspace platform thanks to the huge
audience they can reach great apis and
an incredibly easy runtime with apps
script and a secure and trusted platform
that protects user data we provide
customers with API and app access
controls and visibility across their
Google workspace domain
generative AI is a powerful new Leap
Forward in AI we're excited to unlock
its potential in workspace apps
AI is not new to us building features
with AI safely and correctly requires
deep expertise
our long track record of using AI to
make you more productive speaks for
itself but in some ways we're only just
getting started
looking ahead let's consider two
important places people get things done
in workspace and where AI can help
first apps Gmail docs sheets slides meet
earlier today you heard how AI is making
workspace even more helpful
we recently announced how generative AI
can help you brainstorm and create with
new assistive features in Google
workspace apps now let's talk workflows
people are not just working within apps
but across apps many apps
Gartner recently stated in its predicts
2023 build the digital day of tomorrow
report the application boom has resulted
in the average number of applications
that an employee must use to do their
job reaching 11 in 2022 with 17 percent
of workers needing to use 16 or more 16
apps
with a new Google Cloud generative AI
tools Richard shared earlier and our
expanding apis for Google workspace you
the developer May soon start to build
generative AI powered workflows that can
streamline and automate user texts
across workspace and partner apps
connecting tools and teams
over the last year we have continued to
invest in expanding our platform
capabilities across workspace
we've particularly focused our efforts
on Google Chat and meet apis to ensure
developers can build workflows in these
apps that are so critical to the hybrid
workplace
leading software companies such as figma
atlassian Loom apps are building on
Google workspace helping designers
developers and workers of all Fields get
more done
to better understand our vision for
workflows let's look at an end user
scenario in this instance a product
development workflow
Chris is an engineering manager at
symbol Chris and his team use numerous
apps spanning Google workspace as well
as specialized apps for UI and issue
tracking his team also has to work in
their IDE locate code repost debug
issues and more
Chris has received a request to update
their company's mobile app here are a
few of the steps to get this done
first Chris and his developer team need
to connect and discuss a plan
next Chris needs to meet with the design
team to brainstorm and mock up the UI
and finally Chris needs to update his
leadership and share project details
how can workspace workflows enable users
in this case our friend Chris to use
more of their time and energy on
Creative brainstorming and building the
product and less on chasing links files
and stakeholders
to First connect with his team Chris
starts with an integrated jira chat
house which links to his jira account
he executes the request by simply
creating a jira project right in Google
Chat
his team can discuss what needs to get
done who needs to do it and quickly
update their tracker without missing a b
chat apps can also include AI features
to make work easy for instance Google
workspace customer Red Hat created a
chat app called shadowbot
shadowbot uses natural language
processing to understand intent and
parameters of user queries entered into
the app to quickly get users the right
data
as a second step Chris and the design
team join a Google meet to kick off UI
brainstorm
they collaborate smoothly on their figma
design mocks right in meat addressing
real-time feedback and working together
to quickly get things done
finally when it's time to update
leadership Chris and his team can write
using AI assisted features and docs and
then add third-party smart chips from
figma and jira into the dock these
features make it easy for their
leadership to review a high-level
project plan with the ability to preview
the figma project or the jira tracker
right from the dock
what a productive day and even more
productive because Chris and his team
had real-time visibility into project
progress collaborated easily and made
fast decisions without constantly
switching tools and tabs
next I'm excited to walk you through the
latest Google workspace capabilities
we're bringing to developers that power
these workflows
chat has become a critical connectivity
tool for hybrid organizations around the
world
chat apps for Google Chat allow you the
developer to integrate contextual
workflows and data right into the
conversation
many of our partners like zendesk and
pagerduty are already embedding chat
apps to bring their data right into the
flow of a conversation and allow users
to update records right there
AI capabilities like natural language
processing are great additions to make
chat apps even more useful
workflows powered by chat can help users
quickly take action or respond to Urgent
events which is why I'm excited to share
that chat API is currently in preview
and will be generally available to
developers in Q2
these rest apis let you programmatically
launch new chats and pull data from
chats
Google meet is a workspace app that
allows users to stay connected in the
hybrid workplace
we announced generative AI features for
meet earlier today but we are also
helping bring apps and workflows right
into your meeting
the Google meet add-ons SDK which we
introduced last year and will be in
public preview this quarter enables you
to integrate app experiences into meet
creating an interactive Center Stage
Canvas OR surfacing apps on the side
panel
many of our partners like notion Lucid
atlassian are already building meat
add-ons and we're excited to see what
apps and workflows you build and meets
highly interactive surfaces
also coming this summer to preview
Google meet apis allows developers to
easily add the power of Google meet to
their applications by launching video
calls right from their apps Plus app
developers can pull data like attendee
list event details transcripts and more
from me to extend workflows
finally the Google meet live sharing SDK
lets developers build shared experiences
across apps mobile and web
synchronized media content and shared
controls enabled for all participants
you can create a rich collective
experience for your users
in addition to the Android support that
will be in GA by the end of Q3 we have
added iOS and web support all now in
preview
smart chips enable smooth workflows
across Google Docs sheets and our
partner apps with our new third-party
smart chips you can see previews of data
from external resources like project
thumbnails customer records and
dashboards and more without leaving the
dock you're on we expanded the add-ons
framework to enable our partners and
solution developers to integrate
critical data into Google Docs with
third-party smart chips which are now
generally available and only available
in Google workspace
our Google workspace Marketplace helps
users to discover both publicly
available apps and custom internally
built apps from our developers and I'm
pleased to announce a new category in
Marketplace intelligent apps where users
will be able to easily discover AI
powered apps that our ecosystem
developers build
we're excited to get these latest
platform capabilities into your hands
and can't wait to see what you build for
users and businesses on Google workspace
to get started building I'd encourage
you to join our developer preview
program to get early access to some of
the new features I shared today
follow our YouTube channel to check out
how to videos and learn more about our
platform
thank you for watching and we hope you
enjoy all that io23 has to offer
[Music]
foreign